Úspěch našeho VQE algoritmu silně
závisí na stavu a circuit,
se kterými začínáme.
Jmenuji se Victoria Lipinska a v tomto videu
prozkoumáme možnosti,
které máme při jejich navrhování.
Podívejme se blíže
na všechny prvky,
které máme v každém spuštění kvantové
části VQE.
Začínáme referenčním stavem,
někdy nazývaným počáteční stav.
Referenční stav spustíme
přes parametrizovaný circuit nazývaný
variační forma
s počáteční volbou parametrů
a měříme stav
v bázi Hamiltoniánu
po spuštění přes circuit,
abychom získali střední hodnotu. Nyní
projdeme každý z těchto prvků,
počínaje referenčním stavem.
Typická volba pro referenční
stav je stav nula.
To je stav, ve kterém je kvantový
počítač již inicializován.
Pro problémy kvantové chemie
lze také použít tzv.
Hartree-Fockův stav,
který je výsledkem
Hartree-Fockovy metody.
Stručně řečeno, Hartree-Fockova
teorie poskytuje jednoduchý způsob, jak konstruovat
referenční stav aproximací
základního stavu kvantového systému.
Nalézá rotaci
v prostoru stavů,
která minimalizuje energii základního stavu.
Nakonec referenční stav
může být také velmi specifický pro problém
a možná budeš chtít zvolit
vlastní stav.
V případě, kdy víš, jaké vlastnosti
tvůj systém má – například symetrie
nebo konkrétní počet elektronů
ve stavu – to můžeš použít
pro lepší konvergenci
algoritmu VQE.
Volba dobrého referenčního
stavu je důležitá pro konvergenci –
referenční stavy, které jsou blízko
základního stavu,
mohou problém přivést ke konvergenci
mnohem snadněji a rychleji.
Stejně důležitá
je volba počátečních hodnot parametrů,
které vkládáme do variační formy.
V závislosti na referenčním
stavu a počátečních parametrech proto
můžeme konvergovat rychle, pomalu
nebo vůbec nekonvergovat.
Podívejme se na tento graf
a pro účely vizualizace
si představme, že náš prostor parametrů
má pouze jeden parametr.
Velmi dobrý referenční stav
ti umožní začít velmi blízko
konečného základního stavu
a konvergence pak bude rychlá.
Na druhou stranu, pokud začneš velmi daleko
od základního stavu zde –
referenční stav
a – budeš muset překonat vysokou energetickou
bariéru, která vede k velmi pomalé konvergenci
nebo vůbec žádné konvergenci.
O tom budeme diskutovat podrobněji
v modulu klasické optimalizace
v tomto kurzu.
Podívejme se nyní na parametrizovaný circuit,
který působí na referenční stav – tzv.
variační formu.
Když tento circuit – U(theta) – působí na referenční
stav,
produkuje to, čemu říkáme zkušební stav
psi(theta) nebo někdy ansatz.
Tento ansatz stav je pak
měřen v příslušné bázi,
aby se získala střední hodnota
pro energii.
Variační formy,
o kterých zde diskutujeme,
WEBVTT
jsou motivovány chemií.
Mějte ale na paměti,
že existují také ty inspirované
kvantovým strojovým učením
a dalšími blízkodobými
algoritmy, jako jsou kvantové
přibližné optimalizační algoritmy.
Proberme
některé běžné volby pro chemický ansatz.
Unitární sdružené klastry neboli UCC
je metoda původně navržená
v první publikaci VQE
a běžně se používá v problémech
kvantové chemie.
Typicky,
když parametrizujeme kvantový stav,
pracujeme s exponenciálně
mnoha parametry.
Aby byly přípravné
circuit efektivní,
potřebujeme polynomiální počet
operací
a tedy polynomiální počet
parametrů.
UCC je příkladem způsobu přípravy
zkušebního stavu s takovým circuit
a vychází z metody sdružených klastrů,
která je zlatým standardem v kvantové
chemii.
Nejběžnější volbou je unitární sdružené klastry
singles and doubles
ansatz neboli zkráceně UCCSD.
Protože UCCSD je motivováno specifickou
elektronickou konfigurací problému,
musíme zajistit, aby referenční
stav správně odrážel systém.
To je Hartree-Fockův stav.
UCCSD ansatz obvykle poskytuje
dobrou aproximaci základního stavu,
protože zachycuje jednotlivá a dvojitá
excitace elektronů v dané molekule.
Počet parametrů v UCCSD se škáluje
kvadraticky s počtem
spinových orbitalů.
UCCSD lze velmi dobře
přizpůsobit problému,
ale bohužel kvadratické škálování
stále vede k velmi hlubokým circuit,
které jsou pro současné kvantové
počítače obtížné.
Proto výzkumníci IBM navrhli
heurističtější přístup,
kde lze variační formu přizpůsobit
základnímu hardwaru,
což vede k efektivně
spustitelnému circuit.
To znamená, že zkušební stavy jsou parametrizovány
kvantovými gate
a jsou přizpůsobeny
dostupnému fyzickému zařízení.
Jedná se o velmi heuristický přístup,
který je hardwarově přívětivý.
Na základě těchto příkladů se podívejme
na spektrum možností,
které máme k vyjádření
naší variační formy.
Mnohé z nich
jsou již implementovány v Qiskit,
takže tě povzbuzuji, abys sám vyzkoušel,
která z nich je nejvhodnější
pro problém, který se snažíš vyřešit.
Pokud se podíváme na graf, na jedné straně máme velmi heuristické
variační formy.
Kde je specificita problému nízká, ale
jsou navrženy tak, aby byly implementovány
na reálném hardwaru.
Jsou také vysoce expresivní – v tom smyslu,
že s nimi lze vyjádřit
mnoho kvantových stavů.
Nicméně problém, který se může vyskytnout v pozdější
fázi klasické optimalizace,
je narazit
na tzv. plochý gradient (barren plateau),
o kterém budeme diskutovat v příštím modulu.
Na druhé straně
máme vysoce problémově specifický unitární
sdružený klastr, který funguje
výborně v klasické chemii, ale
WEBVTT
je obtížné implementovat na kvantovém
hardwaru kvůli velké hloubce circuit.
Obecně mohou být výpočty
úspěšnější, pokud dokážeš
za prvé zvolit referenční stav
a počáteční sadu parametrů,
které vytvoří ansatz stav
blízko základního stavu.
A za druhé vyhnout se zbytečným parametrům.
Ty buď zavádějí
větší hloubku circuit bez přínosu,
nebo vytváří větší parametrový prostor
k prohledávání, což vede k plochým gradientům
v klasické optimalizaci.
Které parametry jsou nezbytné je otázka
specifická pro problém,
která vyžaduje pečlivé přemýšlení.
Pojďme si povědět o tom, kde se náš čestný host –
Hamiltonián – skrývá ve všem tomto.
Jak jsme se naučili v předchozí části,
Hamiltonián po qubitovém
mapování je reprezentován jako součet
vážených řetězců Pauliho operátorů.
Nakonec ale
chceme vyhodnotit střední
hodnotu našeho Hamiltoniánu na ansatz
stavu produkovaném variační formou.
Naštěstí kvantová
mechanika je pěkná a lineární
a to použijeme
k získání střední hodnoty.
Takto to funguje.
Víme, že Hamiltonián je vážený
součet Pauliho operátorů –
díky linearitě je střední hodnota součtu
rovna součtu středních
hodnot každého Pauliho řetězce.
To je skvělé, protože jak již víš, měření v Pauliho bázi
je stejně jednoduché jako rotace
standardní měřicí báze.
Místo měření střední hodnoty
na tomto obrovském Hamiltoniánu reprezentovaném
jako součet, nejprve vyhodnotíme střední
hodnoty jednotlivých členů
a na konci sečteme
s příslušnými vahami.
Proto v mnoha zdrojích
uvidíš pouze jednoqubitové rotace
za ansatz.
To implementuje Hamiltonián
v každém spuštění circuit.
V příštím videu
prozkoumáme, co se děje
během kroku klasické optimalizace.
Uvidíme se tam.